I mean in every field there are people
that are very good at what they do in
the superstar defense attorney I mean
I'm not sure who that is on any given
day but I mean I would say there are
people that are very driven that are
very intelligent for the most part and
have ability to convince other people
whether it's the press whether it's
jurors whether it's other attorneys and
whether its potential clients convinced
them that they believe in what they're
saying I would hope so yeah you know I I
don't know I've been in front of a lot
of capable prosecutors I don't you know
I don't know what a superstar sort of
prosecutor would even be you hope u hate
to think that it really matters that
much who's who's the defense lawyer and
who's the prosecutor it probably does
but I think it that would probably
depend on the case and the prosecution
has a very different duty than the
defense lawyer defense lawyer has a duty
to represent his client under any
circumstances and do whatever it takes
ethically and legally to prevail a
prosecutor whether they're a brand new
or whether they're been around and are
very successful are supposed to see that
justice is served and if trying to win
in some unethical way or questionable
way it doesn't matter who the prosecutor
is that's wrong so one hopes that they
take that part of their own
yeah I mean they do have in any
prosecutor's office there's cases that
are stay called they simply don't
prosecute the fact that the police make
an arrest that's the first level and the
prosecutor should really be the filter
you know the police can charge somebody
with you know 20 different charges but
if the prosecutor doesn't feel any of
those warrant a prosecution it's their
duty not to prosecute the person so we
don't really know or we don't hear about
how many situations there are that are
not prosecuted sometimes they see cases
that that are brought that I can't
believe they're brought in the first
place so it's hard to believe that
there's ones that are that are based on
even more spurious arrest but I I know
that there are because I've had clients
come to me that have been arrested in
their cases weren't processed
you